today's mission is to intentionally get
stuck in traffic check this out
complete stand still I've actually
really outdone myself here been here for
about five minutes fun inner city
traffic can be a real nightmare a great
way to spend a hot Thursday in New York
City the traffic is so bad that the MTA
estimates New Yorkers lose an average of
117 hours in congestion each year but
here in London and in Singapore we have
a thing called congestion tolls that
aims to reduce traffic by charging
drivers to enter busier parts of the
city and now congestion tiles are headed
to New York it's going to be implemented
in about a year we're actually
installing the infrastructure of the
cameras in the sensors right now but
here's the thing even though there's a
congestion charge in London and has been
for decades
I'm still stuck in traffic and the roads
have actually been getting slower so do
congestion tolls work how will New York
use them and are these cameras headed
for other U.S cities let's find out so
here's how it works London's congestion
charge Zone covers around eight square
miles in the center of the city and the
boundaries delineated by these red
circles on the road and these signs I've
just crossed over the congestion charge
boundary Zone where I will be picked up
by some cameras that are just up there
that will register my license plate and
charge me 15 pounds to drive in the zone
for the day which is around 19.
it's not actually me that'll be charged
it's my wife because it's all linked to
her account sorry darling so what's New
York's congestion charge going to look
like there you are how you doing nice to
meet you how are you doing to answer
that here's Metropolitan Transportation
Authority CEO Jano Lieber all of
Manhattan south of 60th Street which is
just at the bottom of Central Park uh is
going to in effect be a told area there
are two uh marginal highways on the West
and East side of the island of Manhattan
where you can circumvent the tall we
think the price is going to be somewhere
between 10 and maybe 20 bucks and the
tolls are going to automatically appear
on people's easy passes the MTA told me
it was still finalizing pricing but it
was considering discounts and tax
credits for low-income frequent drivers
and residents it also told me it would
monitor traffic levels around the
congestion Zone to try and avoid a build
up from people avoiding it where will
the congestion charge money be going it
has to be used to improve the mass
transit system but we're not just
maintaining what we have we're building
extending Subway Lines with climate
change and the air quality issues that
all cities are facing there's really no
choice the mtas has the 80 percent of
the money will be used to improve New
York subways and buses while 10 each
will be going to the Long Island
Railroad and Metro North Railroad but
implementing a congestion toll can be
pretty divisive after all these tolls
are designed to make one of the most
convenient forms of transport a
financial inconvenience the MTA has
already received requests from over 100
different groups that believe they
should be exempt or discounted from the
toll from musicians to purse drivers we
have even the farmers have claimed that
they should not be charged there are a
lot of good stories out there but the
bottom line is we have in the United
States we don't have a history of
exempting people from tolls but the
loudest critic of New York's plan has
been New Jersey see folks driving from
New Jersey into New York already pay
between 14 and 17 in tolls when they use
these Bridges and tunnels New Jersey
officials have said an additional
congestion toll would unfairly burden
New Jersey commuters and that a fuller
environmental impact study should be
conducted it then sued the Department of
Transportation New Jersey's actually
initiated a lawsuit against the federal
government for approving our plan
and the governor of New York state has
said respectfully pound sand this is
going to happen so if it's going to
happen can it work can congestion tolls
make roads faster well New York's plan
is yet to get off the ground but
London's has been in place for around
two decades so I went to transport for
London or tfl the government body
responsible for London's transport
networks kind of like the city's
equivalent of the MTA here's Alina Turk
are they effective yes they are
effective
um we found that when we first
introduced the charge traffic entering
the Zone dropped by 18 and congestion
dropped by 30 percent but the problem is
London's roads didn't stay that way over
time congestion levels have started to
go up again tfl data shows that from
2010 to 2019 the average speed in
central London got slower from nine
miles an hour to seven and delays
increased from around 1.5 minutes per
kilometer to around 2.5 so what's going
on why am I still stuck in traffic well
even though some drivers can choose to
switch to a city's public transport
Network others like for higher vehicles
and delivery drivers can't and the
number of those drivers has increased
over the years over 50 percent of the
vehicles in Manhattan's proposed
congestion tolling area are for higher
vehicles and taxes many cities have also
reallocated Road space to buses bikes
and pedestrians there's now also less
Road space available hence that
balancing out the congestion levels but
even if congestion zones don't always
make roads quicker they can have other
benefits one is that they can reduce
emissions tfl say that CO2 emissions in
London have fallen by some 1 million
tons since 2010 in part due to the
congestion Zone but another is that they
can be very good at raising money
whether that was the intended plan or
not it's not a money-making scheme or
hasn't got a revenue raising objective
but nevertheless it does make a net
Surplus
[Music]
so with congestion charging seeming
destined for U.S Street does that mean
we're going to start seeing it across
other cities in the US well Jano hopes
so I I not only think it could work I
know that other cities are watching what
we're doing closely cities from LA to
Seattle have been discussing whether
systems like this could be used to
alleviate their traffic issues and in
London we are getting a lot of interest
a lot of inquiries from cities all
around the world so keep an eye on New
York while its congestion toll will
likely be the very first in America it
might not be the last
oh